a lot of you may have been wondering who
this really shy and bashful person in
the corner not talking to anybody all
weekend has been and that says obviously
judge Alex Kaczynski the Chief Justice
of the Ninth Circuit in California the
Ninth Circuit which has a certain
reputation that we'll probably be
talking about a little bit later and as
you can see a fine actor of his
generation I Alex Kaczynski is well
regarded among people in this room and
outside of this room as perhaps the
foremost libertarian or libertarian
leaning will talk about that to
jurist in the United States a longtime
friend of Reason stalwart defender of
the first and second amendments which he
has posited in previous interviews the
reason back in 2006 is one of the
greatest defenses against government
tyranny he also is very well known for
his certain how to say it ilan in in
writing and various references if you go
in his Wikipedia page I think the first
reference is from a Brigham Young Law
Journal thing saying humor the law and
judge Kozinski's greatest hits
that was from 1992 he's written a few
opinions since then one of the more
famous ones was in the mattel vs. MCA
case anyone remembered that awful I'm a
Barbie girl song we're someone defending
that by the way that became a lawsuit
about various things in and of abusing
copyrights and part of what he wrote is
in the beginning is if this were a
sci-fi melodrama it might be called
speech Zilla meets trademark Kong
and I don't know if it was the closing
words maybe you'd care to amplify that
but the the party's artifice to chill
see there you go Alex was born in
Romania in 1950 left when he was 12
years old his parents were were in the
Holocaust basically in in Romanian whole
cost survivors there went through
Austria first and and ended up here went
to UCLA shot up from Kennedy there okay
I thought so I graduated from there was
at one point in his life probably not
now the youngest Federal Circuit Court
judge in the country I think that
nominated by Ronald Reagan in 1985 and
now he's the Chief Justice the Ninth
Circuit Court welcome
I feel among friends here I want to ask
you I'm irresistible
drawn towards Romania having been there
in 2004 and had my Sheriff Suika and
just being conscious of how the memory
of pre 1989 life continues to sort of
vanish to the extent that you remember
your life before you're 12 can you kind
of share an aspect of what you thought
was a normal childhood that in
retrospect looks a little bit different
well of course this was during the days
of communism and I grew up on the
communism and I actually believed in
communism I consider myself a communist
sorry I was fed this at school and my
parents were careful not to teach me any
wrong ideas because it was well-known
that parents could get into trouble if
children said the other thing in fact
one time I did say something that was
sounded somewhat critical the government
and my father almost lost his job over
it and they were finally persuaded that
it was the kid talking he wasn't but my
father got to talking to him there was a
newspaper called free Romania and they
do you know how to read I said oh yes I
says what can you read here this was
people in my father's office I said what
says free Romania I said but why the
call to Romania all those people are in
prison and
that didn't go over well and after that
my father said well if you ever in
public and I'm there and I do give you
the signal you stop
you don't say another word you don't
explain you just stop talking I said
well what did they ask me question I
said don't worry they're not going to
ask you questions and they never did my
father gave me a signal I stopped
talking and never got in trouble again
but to me that was normal the idea that
you didn't say certain things there when
you had this just the way why it was the
idea that food consumer goods were there
at the whenever the government could
provide them or would provide them and
that if you happen to find something you
bought it because you never knew when
something some necessities been
available to me that was a normal way of
life and we were taught to indoctrinate
in school that we everything that we
have that's good we have to be grateful
to the Communist Party and I believe it
in my heart where the bus to and I
planned when I heard that we're leaving
you know we're going to be behind the
Iron Curtain where people are oppressed
by the voracious Angelini capitalists I
meet with a new I take this knowledge
with me and I would
disinvite them and take it with me and I
would teach the oppressed of the
capitalist world how bad off they were I
did always wonder how come they you know
they're so oppressed how come they have
the Statue of Liberty but I was not
allowed to ask that question but anyway
I had these thoughts in mind I was
firmly of a mind to do that and I
remember being on the train to Vienna
from Romania and having these thoughts
and that's the last time I remember
having them
I then got to Vienna and I discovered
bubblegum and chocolate and bananas and
I became an instant capitalist it was
sort of like whoa and I think it stuck
with me follow my entire life if I I had
me not only lived in an oppressive
regime but having been deluded by by the
government I was a little kid and I
accepted what I was taught but taught me
to be skeptical and it taught me not to
trust what others say particularly
either from the government the idea I'm
from the government I'm here to help you
is I learned that that was always a big
lie and I am intensely jealous of the
freedoms we have as freedoms we enjoy in
this country that you know I must say
all of those of you who had the good
fortune to be born in the United States
you know simply have not known the
absence of those freedoms you know you
can only imagine but not really
experience what it's like to live in a
society with those fears were absent so
I think perhaps I my understanding of
what it means to lose these freedoms and
how important is to to hold on to them
I think perhaps a little more intense
and it would be if I have been born this
country how are your parents
able to leap was it arduous to get out
it was it was essentially impossible
Romania unlike some other Eastern
European countries have no border were
the West so or any of the boy there was
not a possibility so unless the
government allowed you to leave
do it because it finally so fun another
communist country so they would allow
some ethnic repatriation and we're
fortunate that they allowed Jews to
leave we learned later on that was going
on as with the help of the American
Jewish community with the financing from
the American Jewish community
essentially Israel was buying Jews and
it was not automatic my my father having
been a communist and having been a true
believer and having fought and bled for
communism and he was sent to a
concentration camp the worst of the
concentration camp
both of being a Jew and especially the
worst of the worst because he was a
communist jew and he lived and fought
and believed in it and he had the
misfortune of living to see his dream
come true
and see it humble before his eyes and I
think he came to realize I know he came
to realize that this kind of system good
as it may sound on paper or good as it
may sound on first hearing about it and
he was taken in by it the system is a
prescription for a question it's a
prescription to give people power over
other people that is not subject to
lawful control or lawful checks and that
inevitably leads to corruption
inevitably leads to oppression and he
came to realize that that's the system
that he helped put in place and decided
to make all sacrifices to see his son or
my mother as well you know my mother was
not another communist but she of course
was enjoying the benefits of being
married way to a high-ranking party
member but they both decided to give
what was a relatively good position in
in Romania and asked to leave and they
got kicked out of their jobs we were
there for three and a half four years
leather hand to mouth existence
occasionally it was a big secret I was
not allowed to tell people at school
that we hadn't asked to leave but people
found out and occasionally I would get
harassed over it but we made a school
eventually the nation came but they had
to give up everything they had we could
leave with nothing in our pockets you
did you go pretty quickly from Vienna to
California or we spent a year in Vienna
you know I must say again this is
something that most of you here will
never experience but when the Jewish
Family Service took of our case and they
asked us to go and my father said well
you know I know this is probably
hopeless but you know what America that
would be you know and so they said well
can't I and we were there and we just
never dreamed what happened we expected
that sort of like being sent to the moon
you know the Michoud surprised you know
after a few months of waiting it cool
came soon until we actually landed
happen did you speak a lick of English
when you arrived unfortunately I did
well I was I was I spoke we had a
trilingual household my mother spoke
German and I spoke German my father I
spoke Romanian those four kiddush you
know this do that but they had tutors I
went to German school and my I had
tutors in English and piano and French
and so unfortunately I learned English
from a very fine intelligent
well-educated woman
unfortunately spoke English will have a
median accent I still talk like that I
have to ask a variety of people's
questions here since we have legal
thinkers who are a little bit more
advanced than I in the room and I should
say that when when we veer into some
specific cases I'm gonna get shut down
and and so just if I can't talk about
pending cases yes we can talk about
specific cases not gone but pending the
great lawyer many clouds door wanted to
ask when did you first get in touch with
Reason magazine it was in 1970 I was I
had to heard something about
libertarians and I thought of those
Libertines
and my roommate disabuse me of the
notion I said well it sounds interesting
anyway and I was at UCLA and they were
having a rally at USC so I made the trek
all the way across town and there was a
rally I just want to see what these
people have to say I just have been
reading I've and I've I think I've read
every word she's written at least once
but there was a midst of reading I'm
here and I just want to see I didn't
realize there were people who had some
of the same ideas I did so I went
through this valley and there was a
ragtag it's there standing near a car
table was this smiling guy was what was
them really dark hair in shirtsleeves
with copies of Reason magazine and you
know I passed by he engaged me in
communication in a conversation whether
you know Manny you know so we became
instant friends
he's just keep taking magazine and the
man is of course ever sensing that
educated more libertarian ideas it's
been do you describe yourself as a
libertarian do you use labels or labels
not your friend when you want to be a
point you know judge you know as a point
about Republican president I tell you
what I am now if but I I'm not sure I
remember
I generally
describe myself as being libertarian in
philosophy and not everybody fully
understand what it means but I found
over the years is it is winds up being
some a description that more and more
people understand
I was afraid in the beginning that
people would misunderstand what it means
and I think more and more people have
come to accept in this I used to
describe a there's somebody who's a
liberal at home because ever does work
the Ninth Circuit which you preside over
if that's the right word it has a
reputation by some as being super flaky
and the most liberal most liberal courts
in the country I'm sure there are more
colorful descriptions of it that could
be found from this room you've defended
it a little bit from that can you sort
of talk about that reputation what's
what's MIT what's wrong with it or what
so should be modified from it well
there's no doubt about it for many years
the Ninth Circuit was at loggerheads
with the Supreme Court and in to some
extent still as in so the most
contentious and difficult in
cutting-edge cases where there are some
reasonable differences of opinion among
judges the Ninth Circuit for many years
was quite a bit more liberal the Supreme
Court is the consequence of a number of
fact there's not the released of which
was that President Carter appointed some
ten twelve thirteen judges who was sort
of the most liberal judges the world has
never seen trial court and many of them
some of them most of them are still
there many of them are still quite
active
Harry pages and Steve line how selective
and they decidedly view the world from a
different perspective than the Supreme
Court now in most cases that doesn't
matter most cases the law is if they're
not totally political they can't be
divided into liberal and conservative
results and most cases without is pretty
clear but the kind of cases that are in
the headlines the kind of cases were the
issues are our clothes were with the law
is difficult where minds differ where
perhaps Supreme Court hasn't been
entirely clear why hasn't ruled yet the
Ninth Circuit for many years did did
tend to be quite a bit more liberal
Supreme Court and Supreme Court's having
the last word the Ninth Circuit would
get reversed it's been less so in in in
recent years to some extent to a large
extent because there have been quite a
few more so middle-of-the-road judges
both party Republican and Democratic
you've been obviously conversant with
libertarianism for a long time I imagine
that when you're in law school in the
70s there wasn't as large of what you
might describe as a libertarian legal
movements and everything that comes with
that our Damon root writes about this a
lot for the magazine and we've seen a
lot of interesting kind of flowerings of
that Randi Barnett's worked with
commerce clause in the Obamacare case
the landmark gun decisions in 2008 and
2010 what's your perspective on how the
libertarian legal movement has
progressed and evolved over time and and
what what is sort of the significance
and trajectory of it if you can talk in
that kind of generalities well law
schools have been and still are tend to
be very
liberal places and that's just what they
are and so you know that's an
environment that is half welcoming to
libertarians I agreed with what half of
what my professor said I disagreed
really strongly with the other half so
but self-identified libertarians were
quite fair when I was going to law
school there was a libertarian lost you
of socialization bulletin board and you
needed three people to actually go down
physically to to the administration
building in order to get that little
space on the board
I mean prove that you actually have
three people and alumina Abrams van it
for until she graduate and then she
handed the mantle to Marcy Tiffany was
an incoming first year student and Marcy
and she said other where do I get two
more people and she's nobody might I ask
Kaczynski but watch out so he is a wolf
and so I'm the aunt that she came to my
office of the law of you and she said
that he was convinced he and I said yes
and she says I need your body
I was very disappointed that she just
wanted my body to go down to
administration with that but as you know
we got me or even two of our sons are
here can you raise your hands and as
long as we're raising hands can we have
the other ethnic Romanians in the room
Kennedy Katharine menu board and can you
just describe for everyone else's
edification why is it that when they did
something bad in their childhood that
the Gypsy was going to steal them I'm
ashamed if you would say that we they
wouldn't steal them we would sell them
to them
but that's how closely knit the Liberty
community was there was Marcy and me and
this other guy who I think was Hamas
only he went down - can you explain just
real quick the Obamacare decision I know
what I mean to say is do you I guess
this will probably intrude on what you
can't talk about necessarily but what is
the guidance about the commerce clause
that one could interpret I know Randy
Barnett has a pretty optimistic take on
that application and and what not saying
that we've basically limited future
actions by the federal government here
other people are like this is an
incredible defeat just in terms of kind
of instruction and interpret
interpretation where is the commerce
clause now well the Commerce Clause is
has been for the last 50 or 60 years and
you know basically still is the
government can do anything clause it is
how the Supreme Court has interpreted
and you know there are in the Chief
Justice Roberts opinion there are
certain limitations in place but it is
it's a long ways for saying that that
the government is restrained in any
meaningful way at what the truth do it's
in hand of the problem it's in hand in
commerce if you regulate commerce
commerce affects everything and so if
you have the power to regulate commerce
you must of necessity have a power to
regulate other things the problem is not
in the interpretation it's in the clause
itself it's anyways you can cut things
down a little bit and say well it's it's
it's too far away it's too remote but
you're really looking at the margins
everything we do the nature of our
existence is that when a dealing
catalyst
but anywhere is that we depend on
College we depend on Commerce to bring
us things than goods and services that
we need for our existence to make us
prosperous to make us happy
and the government has authority to
regulate it it has authority to regulate
it and it's very difficult to give the
clause a truly restricted meaning the
restrictions it seems to me have to come
from the other parts of the
Constitution's where that lay set limits
on what the government can do to abridge
individual rights the first amendment
second the third amendment work with
ability tubes further than your home the
fourth amendment quite important will be
increasingly more important with
electronic surveillance
it's a highly contentious area as to
what the government can do to look at
the people's lives and can invading
people's privacy but it seems to me
that's where the battleground is I think
trying to rely on the Commerce Clause
which essentially is not a limitation on
government it really is a grant of
authority is is thing you've been very
critical about erosions in the fourth
amendment I don't know if I have the
language in front of me but they're not
I think a 2010 decision maybe it was
Venus really oh I have to dunce yet okay
well we'll face you and look at you in
something our own little private
conversation but it was really intimate
and you kind of ruined for me but you've
been critical about erosions than the
fourth amendment over time can you look
at but what are the what would have been
some of the key to benchmark cases that
contributed to that erosion which which
is bad and also like the conditions in
society or conditions in the making of
law that have contributed to this kind
of erosion or degradation interview of
the Fourth Amendment over the last you
know 40 years 30 years well a lot of it
has had to do with the evolution of
Technology and
the effort of the law to keep pace with
technology he used to be the fourth
amendment just think yourself in the in
the world when the fourth amendment was
passed it was a world who didn't have
fast transportation we didn't have
communication except face-to-face in a
room we didn't have telephone telegraph
any of these internet any of these
things and so the idea was the Fourth
Amendment protected places so if you had
your money in your mattress
let's say or you had say for a desk with
papers in it or if you were at home and
you had a conversation with somebody
face-to-face well the police couldn't
listen in on it the police couldn't come
in and take the stuff without getting a
warrant without and well all of that
broke down with the telephone because
what happened in a case one 1929 the the
police tapped somebody's line so the guy
was in his house talk to somebody other
end the police were outside of the
telephone pole they have the line and
listen the conversation and the claim
was look this was an invasion of privacy
this was an invasion of my protected
sphere of what I expect to be held
secure from the government the
government said no I mean the Supreme
Court said no it's a trespass idea and
since the telephone pole doesn't belong
to the homeowner it belongs to the
telephone company the wires don't belong
teams no trespass no Fourth Amendment
violation well that was in place for
about 40 years and finally in 1967 the
Supreme Court in a case borough of
calves came up with idea finally had
enough of it and what happened in Katz
was Katz was making a bet was having
some sort of illegal conversation
involving gambling in a fool most and
the police knew he was going to be there
cause you
this every day so they had a microphone
on the on the top of the phone booth and
they managed to hear his half of the
conversation and based on that they
convicted him of a crime he said
violation of the Fourth Amendment he
didn't have a warn they didn't have
Howell cause the Supreme Court said
there's a government answer but we
didn't invade the space he was in a
phone booth when the outside Supreme
Court said we're going to jettison the
idea of of trespass and we're going what
we're going to have is a doctrine base
of reasonable expectation of privacy so
what the Fourth Amendment now protects
in addition to places you know
it protects people's reasonable
expectation of privacy which is good if
you have a reasonable expectation of
privacy
so in a world where people use phone
booth to have telephone conversations
that sprinkle could say what you say on
the telephone is private but what
happens in a world when people shout in
their cell phones in the supermarket in
an airport so you can use anybody's
phone conversation just like you could
have heard Cass conversation if you'd
love to do over the booth Oh Supreme
Court could say I don't think it will I
don't think we're going there I'm just
trying to illustrate the problem for you
could say well phone conversations are
really normally considered private we're
so society no longer consider them
private because look at how people treat
them they don't treat them as bribe so
you've got that whole problem and you've
got the problem of the the fact that you
can now no longer communicate without
passing all sorts of affirmations
through a bunch of third parties ice
internet service providers cable
carriers and so on and under another
line of cases the supreme court the
government can obtain any information
you really disclose to third parties
give you an example keep your money in
your mattress at home they can't touch
it they can't look at it
if you without getting a warrant but if
you give it to a bank does anybody keep
the money in a bank or other financial
institution then you've disclosed it to
a third party it's no longer pilot and
the government can obtain it without
complying with the fourth amendment it's
a it's a doctrine that has huge
implications in the era of electronic
communications because basically we
don't ever communicate with each other
anymore
except maybe in the bedroom
that isn't in some way electronically
doesn't go through some sort of
electronic means and this is a huge
problem the Supreme Court justice
Sotomayor wrote about it in a case by
the name of Jones there was a case where
they attached GPS tracker to somebody's
car and the Supreme Court said that was
a violation of the Fourth Amendment
because they attached the GPS tracker to
the car leaving open the question is
what if they can track and
electronically without having to to use
to attach it into the car
incredibly difficult incredibly complex
question
it really will test who we are and what
we think of individual privacy when I
think what finally issues head-on but
you know every one of you every one of
you can contribute to the answer to that
question because every time the idea of
a reasonable expectation of privacy is
not so much what you expect but how we
act as a society and if we treat
communications electronic communications
if you post things on Facebook if you
put things private photos on Facebook
and and other social media sites if you
contribute an environment where as a
society we don't view the privacy of
certain communications of certain
activities as being as being sacrosanct
as being something that we should not
disclose the problem then you contribute
an environment where when the what does
look at it it has views it realistically
in the world say what people must not
care very much about the privacy of
their private photos because what they
post on this on Facebook what the world
can see them they must not care so much
about communications because they shout
them out where everybody can hear so
what I do is if I'm in an airport and I
hear somebody talk
I make myself part of the conversation I
nod you know if they say something said
I look glum and say a joke I laugh I
generally want to make them know that I
am part of their conversation
and I think it's important for all of us
to be aware of this and all of us to be
aware that when you erode when you give
up your own privacy you are not just
giving up your own privacy but you're
contributing to society where the idea
of privacy is undervalued and who's
going to be the beneficiary of that is
going to be the government because you
cannot deny the government anything that
is open to any other party yeah that's
true it's a failure if people treat
things is not private if people disclose
them to everybody in the world what
certainly law enforcement is entitled to
to that as well so be really careful of
it it's a precious commodity there's
something that we take for granted and
it's a it's it's it's it's one of those
things that is going to go away so
quickly and we disappear and it'll all
be our doing we'll look back on it and
ask ourselves who did it and it'll be
like Pogo will say we met the enemy and
he is us let's work our way quickly down
the amendment list real quick maybe a
happier story or a more surprising story
did you imagine when you were first
getting involved in the law that the
Second Amendment would be recognized as
an individual rights bear arms was
that's something that you thought was in
the cards in 1975 or in 1982 how much of
it was a surprise in 2008 certainly in
1975 there was no inkling at all there
was a Supreme Court case mellow Supreme
Court case and everybody interpreted
it didn't exactly say that but everybody
interpreted as saying there's no
individual right to bear arms but then
starting about the mid 80s there were a
series of very serious scholarly
articles written in in law journals that
challenge that notion and that's the
first time I gave the math or any
serious thought I didn't have any
particular agent or two to read about
the Second Amendment I didn't have any
cases and it was not known so my I just
had general knowledge but I saw the
articles and they work really quite
persuasive and once I saw the articles
you know ideas have consequences and
ideas that are well reasoned and
forcefully stated tend to be eventually
find their way to the courts and
eventually find their way into cases and
into our law so once I saw those
articles the first one one of the first
of these was called the embarrassing
Second Amendment it was a little written
by a liberal scholar who found it
embarrassing to actually read the Second
Amendment to decide that it was actually
seemed to say there was a individual
right to bear arms I think it's a better
of their argument I think the Supreme
Court got it right but it was far from
inevitable the world words of the Second
Amendment are clear in one way but I
think they could be rationally
interpreted the other way as well
you're also big fan of the First
Amendment and Chief Justice John Roberts
is I think come out as a pretty
interesting defender of free speech how
would you sort of assess the current
quartz movement on free speech issues
over the last five six years no actually
when it comes to free speech
I think generally the Conservatives tend
to be as or more supportive of free
speech than do the the Liberals
surprisingly Eugene vollis my former law
clerk was teaches UCLA a very famous law
professor constitutional law professor
really brilliant guy once did a way of
the justices along how friendly got of
the First Amendment it turns out the
friendliest the First Amendment's is
Anthony Kennedy my former boss and the
least friendly is Steve dwire Kennedy
was appointed by 4/4 to the Ninth
Circuit by Reagan of course to the
Supreme Court Breyer was appointed by
Clinton so that tells you something so I
think the First Amendment is in very
good shape I I was gratified to see the
Citizens United opinion I thought it was
clearly right and inevitable and I have
no idea why people are tearing out the
hair or saying somehow would say I don't
see how you can come out any other way
if you're honest to the First Amendment
and in the Supreme Court when it when it
comes to the First Amendment both
freedom of religion and freedom of
speech I think I'm very good shape there
and I think we'll continue to me I want
to open it up for questions in one
second but just before that you're
pretty well known as not just a colorful
character but a very colorful writer who
kind of writes almost in a popular style
and some of your opinions what's your
approach why what do you is this just an
expression of your personality or what's
your game
Kozinski
I think law to be intelligible I think
if what I tell my law clerks law clerks
are young lost law graduates who spend a
year working for a judge and essentially
do all the work I do they do drafts and
they you know of course I am the
ultimate say and but they tend to do a
lot of my drafting initial drafting for
me and what I tell them is if you can't
you know I want you to imagine you have
a younger sibling in college so the
college senior maybe and some duis I'm
doing but I'm just saying just imagine
you do and let's say he came to you and
said I want you to tell me what you're
working on today now you're not supposed
to tell your family what you're working
on but just imagine I said would you
explain it in words that somebody like
that would understand if you can't
explain it in words that some but it was
an intelligent interested layperson will
understand then you really probably
don't understand it yourself law is
language the way laws are made they're
only made of words and it seems to me
that a lot of times courts tend to use
ponderous language and obscure language
because using clear language would
expose the fact that they're not very
clear about what they're doing it's much
harder to write an opinion in clear
simple language because you then have to
really think about the fine nuances of
what you're doing and we find ourselves
occasionally drafting a passage in warm
draft we try to do it and rewrite and
rewrite it and every time we try to make
it clearer it gets off kilter and what
we're in as at that point is the reason
is there are two ideas they are fighting
with each other and in time to express
it clearly you either abandon
one idea for favor brother or vice versa
and that forces you to make a choice
between those two simple ideas and so
the process of writing simply I think I
hope leads to opinions that wind up
being more easily applied more
transparent being understood a better
predictor for people who you know after
all people read opinions and they say
how is going to apply to my life we want
things that people can apply to their
lives and have some prediction of the
life so how the next case in the next
case after that will come out so so
that's that's beside that I don't know I
get so bored reading opinions I think
once in a while saying something that's
a little bit different wakes people up
last quickie question before we go to
everyone else just to make a Craig
Franklin sad why don't you like jury
nullification it's it's lawlessness you
know at least with the legislature
you can vote the rascals out and it's a
law that we are ultimately responsible
for but the idea that your faith would
even be found guilty or innocent of
whether you're going to be found liable
or not liable or the amount of damages
you're going to pay it's going to be up
to the law made about 12 people who have
no constituency who got elected to
nothing will never get elected to
anything again who have no one to
respond to you can't take out of office
and your fate your future will depend on
those twelve people making up the law on
the spot it's just just horrendous idea
it's just it's really one of the truly
evil ideas because think about of you we
always think that what juries are going
to do is they're going to take a law
that they find unjust that we all think
is unjust and I'm not going to apply it
well what about did they take a law that
is just and they say we don't like this
defendant we don't like this defendant
because the corporation we don't like
this defendant because he's rich
or white or black or we don't like him
because he has an accent and we don't
have to follow the law and so we're
going to make up the law right now and
find them guilty or find him liable ruin
him financially because we can make up
the law we can do what the legislation
there but the people assemble can do we
can do it in this room we twelve it's a
really frightening idea if anybody has
ever been in front of a jury and I
really had your fate in their hands the
last thing you want is for them to be
able to make up the law as I wish let's
go to questions
you mentioned about social medias where
does the cloud stand you know this where
we are asked to put all our private and
also private information how much
freedom - we have to protect it or not /
are we going back slowly to the country
you and I as I skip from Hungary when I
was at Ryde are we going back to a
system and a situation like the one you
were raised in until further notice I
would not consider anything you put on
the cloud private exactly I'm not saying
it's not going to be but it's a it's a
highly undecided question and afterwards
if anybody says I'll tell you about my
baseball players case and it is a highly
contentious and highly unresolved issue
and essentially if it's a new computer
on your desk when your hard drive where
the police have to actually go in and
get the physical thing it's protected I
mean it's not protects from everything
obviously there's probable cause and
warrant and all those things they're
going to get it
but it's protected from unwarranted
unauthorized intrusion if it's someplace
in the hands of third parties it's like
your bank information you think your
bank officials private what you know
it's not you've disclosed your
information to the bank the government
can get it you've disclosed it to a
third party in the cloud think chances
are very good that if the government
wants it it can take it and some of it
depends on the people who run these the
Internet service providers the the
people who
who handle the cloud storage some fight
back
Google fought back when the Justice
Department asked for certain queries by
by by their users some other search
engines I will not mention did not fight
back some telephone companies are chary
of giving the information about your
location information other phone
companies will for a fee let let law
enforcement ping your phone and they can
ping is often as they want and know
exactly where you are by pinging your
phone because is there anybody here who
doesn't have at least one cell device on
the register I didn't think so so you
know when they ping all of our phones
they will find where the great
libertarian conspiracy is located right
right here but they can do it we are all
talking we have cell phones and our
force we're all talking to cell towers
and certain phone companies were for a
fee actually they have a self-service
website where law enforcement can go in
ping your phone and know exactly where
you are pretty neat huh
so anyway I the answer is
say goodbye kiss it goodbye on that no
we're gonna have we're gonna have to
wrap up thank you so much judge